انضم الينا من اوسلو سفيرا نرويج في
السودان اندرو سيتي اهلا بك سيد اندرو
ونبدا بتقييمكم لما يجري في السودان
تستمر في السودان وهناك معاناه كبيره
للشعب السوداني
الاعزلان
حاولوا الخروج لجلب الحاجات الاساسيه
والوضع كارتي للغايه ويعتقد ان الوضع
سيستمر على حاله لفتره اخرى من الزمن لكن
هناك بعض المؤشرات الايجابيه رايت وطلعته
قبل قليل على
تقرير من دارفور وهناك حديث عن امكانيه
لعقد مفاوضات وهذا الشيء
ايجابي ينبغي التنويه لكن بشكل عام
التراجيديا تستمر في السودان والوضع صعب
جدا
طيب ايضا فيما يتعلق بجهود الوساطه التي
يتم الحديث عنها هناك تحركات سواء
للمجموعه الاليه ثلاثيه او ايضا المجموعه
الرباعيه ولكن هل هناك تحرك فعلي لوساطه
تنهي هذا القتال الدائر يتجاوز ما يتعلق
باجلاء المواطنين الاجانب ومن ذلك
لا اعتقد ان الوساطه هو المصطلح المناسب
الان والشراء الاساسي هو الدفع الاطراف
لقبول وقف واطلاق نار حقيقي و يكون هناك
احترام لهذا الاتفاق
ومن تم يمكن ان نتحدث عن
الوساطه الان لدينا عمليه او محاولات
جاريه على قدم وساقه للتوفيق ما بين طرفين
واذا ما نجحت هذه العمليه يمكن الحديث على
اتفاقه طويل الامد وعوده الى العمليه
السياسيه التي انطلقت في السودان ينبغي
لاي وساطه ان تربط الوضع الراهن بالعوده
بضروره ما كان قائما من عمليه انتقاليه
سياسيه في السودان
ينبغي ان تكون القوات المسلحه في السودان
في المستقبل بعيده عن
السياسيه اي لا ينزلق البلد الى ذات الوضع
الذي يوجد فيه هذا اليوم وبالتالي ينبغي
ان يكون هناك حل شامل للقضيه في السودان
ولكن يظل السؤال عن الكيفيه ان كانت هناك
مرحله اولى تتحدث عنها وهي اقناع الطرفين
بوقف اطلاق النار ماء الاليات التي
تعتمدونها لذلك وانتم ايضا في الترويكا
وتسعون الى اذا التوفيق والوصول الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار كيف
لسنا بحاجه لميكانز كثيره من اجل تحقيق
هذا الامر هناك رسائل واضحه من قبل الاسره
الدوليه والمجتمع الدولي باتجاه الاطراف
المتناحره في السودان بان هناك ضروره لوقف
القتال
واحترام وقف اطلاق النار من اجل فسح
المجال امام
المساعدات الانسان نعلم الوضع الراهن في
الخرطوم وضع متازم الخرطوم طبعا تشهد قتال
كبير وبها عدد كبير من السكان وقد يكون
ميكانيزم مرتبط بالامم المتحده او
بالاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى ايضا بمجموعه
الايجاد كل هذه الاطراف بامكانها ان تتسم
في وضع اليه
لاستمرار الاتفاق اذا هي ينبغي ان يتوقف
القتال ومن تم يمكن التعاطي مع كل
والقضايا اشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد اندرو
سيانس السفير في السفير النواج في السودان
وايضا حدثنا من اوسلو